foreign
Daniel is up next in Atlanta Daniel
welcome to the show
hello
um uh how do you vote um
so Ma I've got a I'm kind of in a world
of of trouble here um
I have about uh 265 000 worth of debt
and uh I just got laid off for my job as
part of the reduction Force um
yeah and
um and no worries I'm pounding the
pavement trying to look for another one
um but uh
yeah that's uh is this a big shock or
has this kind of been on the verge for a
while
oh no it was I didn't nobody knew about
it it was like I mean in fact in fact we
had our CEO tell us um you know uh the
week before that uh you know
and a meeting and the whole company
attended uh there he's like you know you
see all these companies like Amazon
uh Google
um laying off people but um we're not
going to do that and then the next week
that happened so I mean about 200 other
people
wow wow what were you making
uh about 220 uh plus uh bonus would be
20 of my um base and then I got rsas uh
every wow a year as well you were
crushing it so how much money do you
have in the bank right now
um all total uh let me see
um let me find it where I have it on
here uh forty five thousand three
hundred nine dollars and eight cents
okay and do you have anything you could
liquidate to get you by and start paying
off the stat like those stocks are they
vested
well no they once I get terminated they
take them away all the ones they weren't
vested
that's about yeah so what kind of debt
is this are we talking cars can you
break down that debt so we can see where
we can help you out here
yeah
um it's it's a mix of credit cards a lot
of credit
and two car loans and
um one of them is uh so one of them is a
BMW and I'm upside down in that one
um
uh basically uh uh I would have to pay
uh thirty thousand dollars uh to get the
actual value of the cup to you know to
get rid of the car like you owe it's
worth 30 and you owe 60.
yeah like that yeah thanks how did that
happen
bad decisions did you roll negative
equity in
I'm sorry did he roll negative negative
equity from another loan or what yeah
that's that's okay so why do you have
the two cars do you have more than one
person in the household
no um actually the other one is a a car
that um I had a loan on it was a
different kind of loan this is where you
um
you it was kind of like a lot of credit
and I got the title up front and then um
I this is another dumb mistake I didn't
realize that I had done that with that
car and when I got another car I traded
that car in but I still owe it on the
car on the so you don't even have the
vehicle but you still have the data yes
goodness gracious okay all right this is
this is where it gets real because at
this point yeah well here's my question
Daniel truthfully where is this amazing
income been going
uh and then bad decisions give me are
you do you have a spending addiction is
there another kind of addiction I'm
trying to figure out the root of this so
we can help restaurants women
um you know during my 30s and everything
like that and it's built up until now
and so I I can tell you that my
lifestyle is not the same
um and it hasn't been for the past I'd
say four years and I actually started
the debt snowball
um you know I'd say probably
maybe eight months ago
um started it um you know um and again
didn't see this coming but I guess my my
bad decisions from my 30s um you know in
my 40s now
um it's uh crawled up to me and hey so I
want everybody listening to learn from
this right now this is the prime example
of how you cannot out earn stupid like
stupid decisions those decisions they
catch up with you you don't know when
it's coming but I mean here you are your
single guy great income living living it
up basically is what it boils down to
and you're not alone there's plenty of
people doing that and they don't see
that this is a domino effect and it only
takes one Domino to fall for it all to
just you know roll down like that so
this is a Learning lesson not just for
you Daniel but there's plenty of people
listening who are right there and all it
takes is for their their
boss to say all right layoffs are coming
so we're all so many folks are learning
from you right now right now Daniel yeah
so what is your expenses to get by for
one month right now do you have uh rent
is it a mortgage
yeah it's a mortgage um I have a
mortgage and um right now um my monthly
expenses are about ten thousand five
hundred nineteen dollars goodness is
that because you have a giant mortgage
um I don't have I'm paying about thirty
three hundred dollars in my mortgage
yeah that I that's a lot of mortgage
right now for not having the income
well where's the other seven thousand
going this still feels like your
expenses are real high for a single guy
it's it's all the credit card debt yeah
okay these are all your minimum payments
it adds up 265 Grand have you started a
budget yet have you started I know you
said you've kind of start okay so you
you know exactly what you have you know
exactly what your margin could be
um
you're we're not just guessing is
basically what I'm getting no I'm I'm
telling you real numbers like I'm
reading from a cell spreadsheet all
right sweet that's it Daniel here's the
deal I'm scared for you and I'm thinking
through this if I was in your shoes and
if I didn't find a job like the one I
had before where I was making six
figures in the next few months I'm going
I need to look at selling this house and
then taking the net profit and chunking
it at the debt so what what kind of
equity do you have in the house uh right
now about 63
789 okay and plus you're 45 that would
knock out a good portion of your debt
over a third and and I've been told by
my realtor that you know she's thinking
um the area that I'm in that I could
make uh 75 to 100 000 profit from the
selling the home okay so even though you
have 63 in equity based on the sale
price you could make more even after
fees right so let's look at the career
side of it then with your job I mean how
quick let's be realistic if you really
you said you're hitting the pavement how
quickly could you find something where
you're making even if it's because let's
let's look at it on two sides you need
to get anything right now get any job
you know it's not may not be the dream
job but anything to float you until you
do get the dream job right
sorry okay so don't wait around for a
300 000 job yes go drive for Uber until
you make 150 and then jump to 250 when
you can yeah anything to stop the
bleeding because here's the thing if you
can get back to making 220 250 and you
can throw 130 000 at debt you're debt
free in two years so this is not a
hopeless scenario it just feels like
that right now because you got punched
in the face while you had a pile of debt
in front of you
right I also wanted to ask this question
too um so I have a 401k and it has about
um I can withdraw about three hundred
and two thousand dollars from it um
should I leave that alone uh because I
could pay off my debt right now with
with you know the 401K I'll leave it
alone
okay in your 40s starting from scratch
it's there's too much growth potential
that will happen from that 300 000 for
you to liquidate that pay the penalties
pay the Inc it's just it's just triple
stupid so I would use your future income
you're not scared of work you're gonna
find that great job again you're gonna
pay off this debt in the worst case this
house sale is Your Parachute to get out
of this thing and at least go rent for a
while and get out from under this giant
mortgage and get some roommates or
something major lesson learned man I'm
so sorry Daniel are you hoping you find
that next job soon
I I appreciate it and yeah it's uh
definitely
one of the the low points of my life I
can tell you that for sure tough tough
tough stuff look Daniel's not all that
different we know a third of people who
make over 250 000 are living paycheck to
paycheck yeah and this is why you get
that big income and you're like oh a
lifestyle whatever I want you can have
it earn your stupidity when you make 300
Grand and everyone thinks if I just made
that much man I would be different for
me yeah right listen nobody's above it
we have to make these decisions every
day to stay out of debt to do the right
thing to have that money in the bank and
we don't owe anyone anything a layoff is
a lot less scary but I'm glad Daniel's
at least got some cushion there with 45k
in the bank to float them by until he
can find that next gig but scary
situation right now